you're playing on the hardest difficulty
in the game unbeatable this is the first
time that I've ever played a video game
with someone who has actually been in
the experience that we're doing run into
hard you really pay the price and that's
really accurate to real-life Jeb the
first thing I noticed when we sat down
is how late your skill set completely
translates into the game it does for
sure the breaking the arc in the corners
it's all very very similar
you can feel the draft right here hey
guys and by the way we are on the we are
on the hardest difficulty in the game
you're whizzing by guys and also look at
your mirrors almost came across Kyle
Busch's nose right there any elements
crash right so what what is it my
strategy in a really start do I want to
do I want to stay in the pack don't
wanna I usually give myself probably
about five or six foot gap in between me
in the next car and I'll try that time
when the guys in front of me are gonna
go so I can get a head start on the guy
in front of me I can pull down and make
that pass for getting the turn one pack
racing and drafting in the pack what are
the strategies there it's just like the
game you're sucking over the guy in
front of you and you can kind of
slingshot around I'm kind of like you
know the Ricky Bobby movie how you shake
and bake a little bit and the game
actually will show you in the UI that
you're drafting and it will change audio
cues perfect draft perfect draft I love
that how do you know when to draft and
when not to drive well drafting down
straightaways is a lot better than in
the corner just because you're out of
the gas and the corner and you're trying
to let the car handle and I don't know
what's been going on the last minute but
I've got past so hot well it's cuz I'm
talking your ear off you also like I
should say again you're playing on the
hardest difficulty in the game
unbeatable it does have the haptic
feedback on the on the triggers to try
to give you that that sense of Roma
because I know I mean just as a person
that drives a car in life so much of it
comes from feel not from looking and
listening for sure like I said about
corner you can feel this thing vibrate
I'll show you right here I can feel it
it's vibrating right now
sliding through the front tires now how
do you prepare to race a track for the
first time I'll watch a lot of for our
races and I feel like this would be an
amazing tool as well actually this would
because everything on this game is just
like real life if you look around to the
grass where the entry to the pit area is
it's amazing to be able to have like the
authentic teams and also you know the UI
is giving you stuff that you don't have
in real life like you know telling you
you've got people to the right to the
left of you well I have a spotter that
grandstand right there at most
racetracks telling me inside outside
when to pit that's pretty cool there's
now pitting in Forza as well how do you
determine when it's time your tires will
wear out so or if you have a vibration
with the tire going down or gonna have a
problem you can pit but that is very
cool man yeah there's a lot of settings
that you can tweak what would you mess
with and I'll start like right here at
the right shop and everything the team
does the stuff we're doing on the game
right here is kind of a little bit of
that sure we can mess with the tire
pressure a little bit we'll go down so
the trade-off you're making is
performance but it's gonna wear quicker
so you might have to make a pit stop
quicker it's risk versus reward
rebounding shocks more rebounders grip
drivers love downforce and side force
there's the more downforce you have the
facts are you're gonna get so let's
crank it up why wouldn't we want to
crank it up we're gonna crank that well
anyway up so do you already feel the
difference I did yeah the car is turning
better the the car this has overall more
grip I love how you know it's so cool
you just feel it
are you well I just caused a big wreck
whoops you can push why well yeah why
bad
yeah I needed a couple weeks ago